in 1950 Computing Pioneer Alan Turing
predicted that within a few decades
computers would convincingly mimic human
intelligence
as artificial intelligence rapidly
evolves many people worry that machines
will go from imitating people to making
us obsolete
but some Stanford Graduate School of
Business professors believe that too
much attention has been paid to the idea
that algorithms or robots will replace
people
using AI to take the place of human
intelligence and labor is a powerful
idea but it's a very limiting one
we can use AI to complement people by
enabling them to do new things
both Automation and augmentation can
create benefits and both can be
profitable
the idea that AI is aimed towards
automation is a misconception there's so
much opportunity for this technology to
augment humans than the very narrow
notion of replacing humans
here's an example of how augmentative AI
is making people more productive
doctors are using AI tools to sift
through mountains of medical literature
and process paperwork more efficiently
imagine how that frees up medical
professionals to do the work that
inspired them to get involved in the
field in the first place
this type of assistive technology Lee
says is a win-win AI is not taking away
from the human element but it's an
enabler to make human jobs faster and
more efficient
building a future where AI boosts human
potential will require Business Leaders
to understand the risks of this new
technology
that framing is not going to come from a
typical master's degree holder in
engineering it's going to come from
business people from those with a
background in social science ethics or
policy
there's a Gold Rush right now about ways
to apply these incredibly powerful
machine learning techniques Brittany
olfson says but there is a big gap in
getting the economics and business side
to catch up to each other
the question is how can we do this so
it's consistent with our values
most progress over the past thousands of
years has come from doing new things
that we never did before not from Simply
automating the things that we were
already doing
that will require us to tap into a
superpower that can't be programmed into
a robot imagination
[Music]